they faced off with walker bueller who
has thrown just
eight innings over the last month
because of that blister now
four of those innings came in the wild
card round against milwaukee last week
and he was really good with eight k's
and four
that is shot to the left side turner's
waving on it ambitions the first out of
the night 2018 pen and run
there goes tatis again on strike three
throw down
not in time and a stalling base for
tatis
on a 3-2 hosmer rips one right side and
a bounce it's taylor he will
throw to first in time down to scoreless
first inning for walker builder
so here we go mike clevenger quieted up
the deadline from cleveland was doing
some great things for him he had a seven
inning shutout
then the elbow impingement he's pitched
just one inning since september 13th
betts looks one to right field there's
where myers for the first shot of them
on this one two he chases a similar
pitch klevinger gets him for the second
half
alma the two one will smith pulls the
liner to short and tatis is there to
ambient
this is loaded for the padres and uh as
padres fans know they
really good in these situations he
sticks with the fastball and strikes him
out
big strikeout for walker b they're two
gone here in the second
grisham had 10 home runs on the year the
3-2 he
strikes out swinging a 99 mile an hour
fastball
into and out of trouble for walker
bueller
and the reigning mvp cody bellinger to
lead off this second against mike
clevenger
he misses upstairs with his first one
it's 1-0
there's gonna be a lot of things about
this year it's gonna be hard to judge
yeah jace tingler's on his way out the
first pitch fastball to bellinger was 90
miles an hour uh-oh yeah the 90 mile an
hour fastball is
is is not good he's done yeah oh this
padre post season has been so terrific
they've overcome so much
and now they have to overcome even more
no question about it
fueler needed 53 pitches to get through
the first two innings here's his 14th to
the third to finish off
hosmer on a 1-2-3 inning by far his
cleanest tonight in for his major league
debut here in the postseason is ryan
weathers how about this go get him kid
welcome to the postseason
slurve seeger lashes one on a line to
center for grisham
he gets the first down to the big league
career that's got to be a big old deep
breath
i'm a big lead fighting with his
mechanics and i'm sure after the game
he'll talk about maybe not being
comfortable
myers at first base is running and the
one pitch swung on and missed the throw
from smith not in time
will myers steals a bag that's the third
of the night for the padres against
bueller and smith
and now a two-out runner and scoring
position for austin nola now the pitch
to nola fastball down the middle lined
into left field coming over paula can't
get there
bounces in front of him myers will round
third he comes in and score
and on an 02 pitch austin nola
with an rbi single in the padres strike
first one to nothing here in the fourth
so the dodgers with an opportunity with
two gone here in the fourth inning
austin adams having to face mookie bets
with the bases loaded in a one-run game
no balls and two strikes the pitch to
bets is a slider and it's hitting the
air out towards left field pro far's
going back
still going back in front of the warning
track he's there to make the two-handed
catch
and that's it for the dodgers in the
fourth inning richards to bellinger
the 2-2 left it over the plate got away
with it at second base
right thrown against by hosmer and the
dodgers have tied the game
it's a defensive lapse that allows the
dodgers to get on the board
so the dodgers still don't have a hit
but they have a run
two walks and an air
now it's pollock with runners at the
corners in two gun
breaking ball lifted in the air to deep
left field since pro far
back to the edge of the warning truck
he's got it to
end the enemy taylor at first good
wheels
as best watchers one just missed ball
two
[Applause]
trying to chase that first title since
88 here he pokes one down the line to
left that's into the corner
profile races over to play the cam
taylor stops at third
on a ringing double from nukey second
and third with one going in a one-one
game in the six
days
you would not want to lose your manager
and again with this many decisions to
make and he just did
jace tingler's been thrown out of the
game by lance barrett
and so it'll be up to the rest of his
staff to navigate these bumpy waters
tied at one bottom of the sixth second
and third for the dodgers after their
first hit
the infield pulled in for the padres
seeger hits it sky high to medium deep
left field
tagging at third as taylor profile
settles under makes the catch
here comes the throw to the play
taylor's in safely and the dodgers have
taken the lead
[Applause]
turner shoots one through the right side
base set that's headed for the play
bill still standing up and the dodgers
lead 3-1 as turner drives one in
more runs bad today than any player in
the postseason in dodger history
that's number 36. we're going to put
smith on intentionally and uh
the lefty lefty match up with belgium
ground ball up the middle crowded worth
lays out to get there but
everybody's safe and they lead it
forward and an infield hit from cody
bellinger to score justin turner
had to leave early that one gets by
charging home from third is muncie and
they lead 5-1
everybody advances a wild pitch from
stamen allows muncie to score
first things first with the left-hand
hitting corey seeger swinging at the
first pitch and lining it
into the shift where manny makes the
catch in shallow right field
we've been calling it the manny shift
all season long and that is exactly
right
why the third baseman goes all the way
out to the other side of the diamond
20 or 30 feet back onto the grass dodger
bullpen tonight four innings one base
runner yeah they've been outstanding
strikes out myers-seaway for out number
two of the nine
[Music]
[Applause]
the dodgers take game one five one